>> RIGHT NOW THIS IS A
POLITICAL LOSER FOR THEM.
THEY INITIATED IT.
THEY THOUGHT THIS WAS A
GREAT IDEA.
AND AT LEAST FOR THE
SHORT-TERM IT HAS BEEN A
COLLOSAL, POLITICAL MISTAKE.
>> Sean: THAT WAS SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER LEADER MITCH
MCCONNELL EARLIER TODAY
POINTING OUT THAT THE YES
SCHUMER SCHIFF SHAM SHOW WAS
A MASSIVE STRATEGIC ERROR
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
IT WAS A WASTE OF TIME AND
IT HAS NOT HELPED OUR
COUNTRY.
AS LEADER MCCONNELL’S OFFICE
NOTED THE DEMOCRATS THREW
THE KITCHEN SINK AT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TENDED IN NOTHING BUT A FULL
AQUILTS FOR THE PRESIDENT.
JOINING US NOW THIS IS A
GREAT BOOK ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT OUR JUDICIARY IS
AND ALL THE JUDGES THAT HAVE
GOTTEN APPOINTED THANKS TO
THE HARD WORK OF SENATOR
MITCH MCCONNELL THE SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER IS HE SIR, I
WATCHED TODAY AND I WATCHED
YOU CLOSELY THROUGHOUT THIS
WHOLE PROCESS.
AND YOU WIN AGAIN.
I’M NOT SICK OF WINNING BUT
I SAW A PARTY FOR THREE
YEARS ANGRY, UNHINGED.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEY
LOOK DIMINISHED AND
INSIGNIFICANT CAN’T TO ME.
THAT’S HOW I SEE THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> I COULDN’T AGREE WITH YOU
MORE.
THE BEST EVIDENCE OF THAT
AND YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT, I’M SURE, FOR 24
HOURS.
IS THE SPEAKER TEARING UP
THE PRESIDENT’S SPEECH.
HOW CHILDISH AND PETTY IS
THAT?
WHAT KIND OF EXAMPLE DOES
THAT SET FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT HOW WE OUGHT TO
CONDUCT OURSELVES?
I MEAN, HAVE WE FORGOTTEN
HOW TO BE CIVIL TO EACH
OTHER?
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE ARE IN
CONGRESS, SITTING TOGETHER,
NOT OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
NOT AT RALLIES.
BUT AT LEAST AMONG
OURSELVES, WE OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO DISAGREE AND NOT
BEHAVE LIKE A BUNCH OF
CHILDREN.
>> Sean: SENATOR, EVEN
THINGS THAT THEY SUPPORTED
IN OBAMA’S SECOND TERM LIKE
PROTECTING OUR BORDERS WHERE
90% OF THE HEROIN CROSSES
INTO THIS COUNTRY, ONCE
DONALD TRUMP PROPOSED IT,
THEY DIDN’T SUPPORT IT.
YOU’RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: TELL US WHAT YOU
SEE, WHAT YOU OBSERVE BEHIND
THE SCENES?
WHAT IS DRIVING THEM?
>> WELL, THE BEST EVIDENCE
OF IT HAS BEEN ON DISPLAY
THE LAST TWO OR THREE WEEKS.
THE MOST AGGRESSIVE THING
YOU CAN DO TO ANY PRESIDENT
IS TO TRY IMPEACH THEM.
AND THEY DID IT.
ON A PARTY LINE VOTE.
AND YOU COULD BEST DESCRIBE
IT AS TRUMP DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHATEVER HE
IS FOR, THEY ARE JUST
PAVLOVIAN RESPONSE TO IT
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
THE THING TO TAKE AWAY HERE
AND I SAID IT IN MY PRESS
CONFERENCE TED AND I THINK
YOU LED WITH IT, THIS WAS A
THOROUGHLY POLITICAL
MANEUVER.
IF IT WAS, IT WAS STUPID.
IT BACKFIRED.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE BEST
NUMBERS HE HAS HAD SINCE HE
HAS BEEN IN OFFICE.
MY MEMBERS WHO ARE IN TOUGH
RACES ARE ALL LOOKING AT
BETTER NUMBERS THAN THEY
WERE BEFORE IMPEACHMENT
STARTED.
SO, IF THIS WAS ALL ABOUT
THE NOVEMBER ELECTION, IT
SEEMS TO ME WE CAN CONCLUDE
AT LEAST IN THE SHORT-TERM
HERE THIS WAS A COLLOSAL
POLITICAL MISTAKE ONE QUICK
QUESTION ABOUT SENATOR
ROMNEY.
I FELT HIS SPEECH WAS ALMOST
INCOHERENT IN THIS REGARD.
HE JUST EXONERATED OUT OF
NOWHERE JOE AND HUNTER
BIDEN.
I’M LOOKING FORWARD TO YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT.
THEN HE GOES INTO LONG,
LENGTHY ARGUMENT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT ONE VOTE OF HIS TODAY?
>> WELL, I WAS SURPRISED AND
I WAS DISAPPOINTED.
BUT, MY JOB IS TO TRY TO
WINS A OFTEN AS I CAN IN THE
SENATE.
THERE IS ALWAYS THE NEXT
VOTE.
SENATOR ROMNEY ON THE WHOLE
HAS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IN THE YEAR THAT
HE HAS BEEN THERE.
I THINK THIS WAS A MISTAKE.
I DISAGREE WITH IT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WE HAVE A
LOT MORE VOTES TO CAST
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER.
AND I’M GOING TO NEED HIS
SUPPORT ON A WHOLE VARIETY
OF THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO THE PRESIDENT AND TO THE
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: AS THE PRESIDENT
LISTED ALL OF THE ECONOMIC
SUCCESS AND FOREIGN POLICY
SUCCESS, SOLEIMANI,
BAGHDADI, THE CALIPHATE, ET
CETERA, ALL THE TRADE DEALS
AND ALL THE NEW JOBS
CREATED, IT’S A PRETTY LONG
LIST, SENATOR, THAT SEEMS TO
ME IF YOU ASK THE QUESTION
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU
WERE FOUR YEARS AGO THE
ANSWER IS YES.
>> NO QUESTION PEOPLE ARE
BETTER OFF THAN THEY WERE
FOUR YEARS AGO.
THAT’S THE CENTRAL THEME
UNDERLYING THE PRESIDENT’S
FALL CAMPAIGN.
AND HE DID A MASTERFUL JOB
LAST NIGHT OF LAYING ALL
THIS OUT IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AT A TIME
WHEN A LOT OF THEM ARE
TUNING IN AND PAYING
ATTENTION.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS WERE LEFT
WITH WAS SORT OF POUTING ON
THE FLOOR, YOU KNOW, TRYING
TO AVOID ANY KIND OF
POSITIVE RESPONSE TO
ANYTHING HE SAID.
I THOUGHT IT WAS CHILDISH
AND SILLY AND COUNTER
PRODUCTIVE FOR THEM.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, SENATOR,
WE APPRECIATE IT.
YOU WON THIS BATTLE LIKE YOU
WON THE JUDGE BATTLE AND
KAVANAUGH BATTLE.
THE PRESIDENT OBVIOUSLY IS
WINNING FOR THE COUNTRY.
I’M NOT SICK OF WINNING.